joining us in the lobby of Ramsey
solutions of Paul and Molly are here hey
guys how are you better than we deserve
Dave how are you awesome welcome
where're you from
we are from Moscow Idaho cool very cool
and all the way to Nashville to do a
debt free scream yes sir we had to get a
credit card to get here but we could do
it okay next caller
okay sorry back got a bad connection
here pause sorry I thought you said a
credit card how much debt if you guys
paid off
we paid fifty one thousand six hundred
and sixty six dollars and forty nine
months way to go dude
and what was your range of income during
that time we started around 25,000 with
three different jobs and then ended
around 45,000 with full benefits Wow
what do you guys do for a living I am
now a youth pastor Emily I stay at home
with the kids very cool
good for you excellent excellent what
kind of debt was the 52,000 oh geez
bunch of stupid tax car loans student
loans car credit cards
yeah school loans okay everything yeah
you were normal yeah yeah so what
happened 49 months ago that made you
decide you needed to get out of debt
should Kidada should get out of that and
could get out of that well I had lost a
job in Montana and then we moved back to
Southeast Idaho and while I was there
working at a restaurant serving I listen
to this crazy guy in the radio yell at
people about how a dumb they are with
their money and one night he was yelling
at those husbands that put all the
financial stress on their on their wives
and it clicked that that was me oh and
so I came home and I said honey I think
we should get a debt and she I was like
I was trying to do this six years ago
but okay let's go so we uh we took FPU
and it started going cos all intense and
now we're here finally the rest as they
say is history
yes but you guys I mean you've paid off
a lot of debt with not a lot of income
no I mean you have torn through this
hard so what was the secret with making
twenty five to forty five thousand to
paying off fifty two thousand well we
did the budget and that helped a lot and
I scraped back our meal plans as much as
possible and he was working at the
restaurant when we first started so that
helped his meal budget scientist
to worry about me and the kids and I was
working for my dad for a little while so
that helped - mm-hmm but I think that
was probably what helped the most yeah
the budget was key sticking to the
budget and learning had to say no
learning to believe that really we have
enough we don't need more we don't have
to have nicer cars master nicer clothes
we don't have to buy our kids the toys
or the cookie to make us feel better as
parents mm-hmm really just trying to
believe that we we already had enough
and we just need to stick with the plan
so you're a youth pastor yes sir as you
went through this process what was the
spiritual experience that you guys have
really realizing the type of life that
we live in the consumer world how we're
always being forced this lie that we
have to have something more to fulfill
who we are that we haven't have X Y & Z
in order to really measure up to to the
rest of society mm-hmm so learning what
about that cool very cool
good job all right and you brought the
kiddos with you what are their names in
ages we have eyes Olivia she is - we
have Isaiah who is four and micaiah who
is six very cool very cool well
congratulations you guys I know you feel
great very proud of you
thanks for making the trip all the way
to Nashville to do your debt-free scream
live I hope you enjoy your time here
all right very cool all right Paul and
Molly and the gang from Idaho $52,000
paid off in 49 months making 25 to 45
thousand a year count it down let's hear
a debt free scream three two one
that is how it's done man I love it I
love it I love it way to go you two very
well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind